Well, you'll probably have an assistant, I would hope, in this
time next.
That'll cut down on your nights to only every
other one. Yeah.
Hey, the goal is to
get the information, make it relevant. Yeah, there you
We have karaoke tonight.
I don't know if you want to hear me
sing. I suspect not.
That's good music. All right,
we would not be expecting
that. She breaks out Lights
go down.
Hey, everybody up here ready?
Testing, testing. Okay.
Yep, I don't— the only thing
better is if you had the infinity screen with the
infinity sign.
OK, we'll wait for— Right
now. OK, all right. It is— thanks for the
technical expertise to keep us sounding clear for
the recordings or for the meeting log.
We will go ahead. It is 5:31 PM on Tuesday,
September 8th. We'll go ahead and begin our
Planning Commission, our work session. And we will have
a training by— I'm guessing this is with Marcus—
for on ethics.
OK, you have— we have— you have our attention and
we are ready to go. Thank you, Marcus.
Yeah, we gotta like not set the default to
monitors, but whatever. It's fine. We're good. We're good. You got
it. Okay, let's— sorry. You just
have to know to pull it off your imaginary screen. Yeah, well, now I can't
see it on my own screen. I got to look down here to see the
slideshow. There we go. From beginning. There we go.
Okay. So we are here to talk
about ethics and Open and Public Meetings Act.
Okay. So we're going to start with the video. And some of you
may remember this. This is a somewhat edited version from a
training I've done with some of you, but not all of you, so we're going
to— you have to bear with me if you've seen this before.
Okay. There we go. I tell you, I got
to plead ignorance on this thing, because if anyone had said anything to me at
all when I first started here that that sort of thing was frowned upon,
you know, because I've worked in a lot of offices, and I tell you,
people People do that all the time. Okay, so obviously
pleading ignorance is not any sort of defense to any of
these things, so it's important to be trained and understand kind of what our
obligations are as members of the Planning Commission. So let's—
all right. Okay. Open and
Public Meetings Act. We're going to start there. So it is the intent of the
legislature that the State, its agencies, and its political subdivisions
take their actions openly and conduct their deliberations openly.
So that is the public policy surrounding the Open and Public Meetings
Act. The Planning Commission is subject to the act, and so
you have to abide by it, and thus have to understand what it
is that your obligations are. Okay,
so the default rule is that a meeting is open
to the public. As a planning commission, I think I'm aware of one time
in our city's history where a planning commission has ever gone into closed. Session,
or one incident that led to— may have been multiple meetings where they went into
closed session, but it was regarding the same situation. So it's
not something that's likely that's going to come up during your tenure, but it is
possible, so it's good to understand how the procedure works.
So again, the default rule is it's open to the public, and it can only
be closed for very specific reasons under
the statute, none of which are likely to apply. The one prior situation had
to do with reasonably imminent litigation, which is one of the reasons, or pending litigation,
which is one of the reasons that you may close a meeting.
Requires a 2/3 supermajority vote, which in the case of
5 voting members is 4 votes.
Extremely unlikely you'd ever close a meeting, but could
happen. Okay. So in order to understand this, you need to understand,
one, the term meeting is actually a defined term in the statute. Here's the
definition. I think I will skip reading it. You can
read that first section yourself, but that is the basic definition.
But the gist of it is a quorum, plus you're discussing public
business that's within your jurisdiction, that is a meeting.
It's a little bit more complicated than that, but that's the general gist
of it. It does not have to be in person. It could be phone calls,
video conferencing, emails, text messages, et cetera.
It doesn't have to be any formal setting. A quorum is
3 members of the body in your situation.
So, because we have 5 voting members, it's a majority.
OK. So here is an example of what not
Members of the Commission, Mr. Vorstein is pleased to be here
today. And when the day finally came, I was ready. I felt so
confident that all I had to do was present my case. And we have documents,
one of which is a report by retired FBI agents which
completely absolves Mr. Rothstein from any wrongdoing. I'd like this
marked. Pardon me, Counselor, before you continue. No, I want to have this marked.
This, uh, this commission is prepared to act on a motion denying the Rothstein
application. Denied! Do I hear a motion seconded? Mr. Chairman.
Mr. Chairman, I second the motion. Do I have a vote on the motion?
Mr. Chairman. Aye. Aye. Aye.
The ayes have it. This hearing is adjourned.
Okay. So here,
obviously, you wouldn't think that the movie Casino is about
Open Meetings Act, but here you'd be proven wrong.
So the gist of it is that they
obviously had already decided what they were going to do in advance,
and this would be illegal under Utah law.
So individuals constituting a quorum of a public body, So again,
3 individuals in the case of the Planning Commission, may not act together outside
a meeting in a concerted and deliberate way to predetermine an action to be taken
by the public body at a meeting on a relevant matter. So relevant matter
is a defined term in the statute. It means something that's within
your jurisdiction to act on.
So, okay. So again, here's some miscellaneous rules.
Again, quorum is 3 members. Chance for social meetings.
If you go bowling together and you don't talk about city business,
that's, you know, Planning Commission business, that's fine.
You can have all of you together going to social meetings. I wouldn't necessarily recommend
it based on my own history and experience that those things sometimes—
what do you have that's in common among you all? You're on the Planning Commission,
so those types of subjects tend to come up. So I wouldn't necessarily recommend it,
but in and of itself is not a violation of the Open and Public Meetings
Act. But again, it states in the statute it cannot
be used to circumvent the requirements of the statute. So you
can't say, hey, let's go bowling and discuss this rezone.
So, and the last thing that's kind of a miscellaneous
rule is you can only take action on items that are properly noticed. So sometimes
people come and they wanna, it's more common in city council
meetings, but it could happen here. Where you wanna talk about, hey,
this is something that we should put on the agenda, or here's something I prepared.
I know in past Planning Commissions, there were some very proactive Planning Commissioners
that would draft code that they wanted, you know,
without reference to any staff members or their expertise,
and they would want to run it through the Planning Commission and send
it to City Council. So, I mean, that's,
you can do that. But you can't just
bring it up in a meeting. It would have to be noticed properly.
So in the case of anything pretty much in your jurisdiction, it would
be public hearing and would require a 10-day notice.
Okay. So hypothetical 1.
Planning Commissioner A meets with Planning Commissioner B
to discuss a preliminary plat application coming before the Planning Commission on the next agenda.
Commissioner A convinces Commissioner B that the preliminary plat does not meet legal
requirements. They decide to vote against it the next meeting. Is this a violation of
the Open Public Meetings Act?
Yes. Yes. In spirit,
probably. No. No. It is not. It's not 3.
They are not a quorum. So that is the key issue here to highlight.
It is okay, again, Ideally, again, the spirit,
you gotta remember the spirit of the Act is that these things occur in a
public meeting, in the open. However, it is not against
the law for one of you to discuss with another one of you issues
coming on the upcoming agenda, if you want.
Even if you decide, hey, I know this is what I'm gonna do, like,
you should, I think, you know, as legal counsel, I would advise
you to keep an open mind and to see seek
advice and all that and discuss and not make decisions in
advance of the meeting. That being said, I'm here to instruct you on
the law, and what the law says is that if it's
not a quorum, then it's technically lawful, you know, in this situation.
So, okay, hypothetical 2.
Commissioner A speaks to Commissioner B about a rezoning application in front of the Planning
Commission next week. He convinces Commissioner B Excuse
me, I used the male gender in all of these,
so I guess, you know, males tend to be up to no good
more often, so. No,
he convinces Commissioner B to recommend approval. Commissioner B speaks to
Commissioner C to get his support. Commissioner C dislikes the rezone application,
declines to give support. Is this a violation of the Open and Public Meetings Act?
So the trickier this year, so— It involves 3, but it
doesn't involve all 3 at the same time, right?
So technically it's not a violation,
but it feels weird. Would be. I probably wouldn't
do it. Yeah. I would say no, it's not a violation.
Anybody else? Agree, disagree,
don't know? Okay, let's go back
to the— okay. Individuals constituting a quorum of
a public body may not act together outside. So we have 3 individuals here,
so that would be a quorum. May not act together outside a meeting in a
concerted and deliberate way to predetermine an action to be taken by the public body
at a meeting on a relevant matter. So again, I would say that this is
a violation, even though they don't necessarily all come to the same conclusion.
They did meet with the intent to predetermine an action to be taken by the
public body, and they did constitute a quorum.
And this section of code specifically contemplates
not all together at one time.
So it is actually, I think, a violation. It's a little bit more of a
gray area because they don't actually predetermine the action to be taken.
They only attempt to do so. But I do think that that would actually be
a Technical violation, and in addition to a violation of the spirit of the Act.
Okay. Hypothetical 3.
Planning Commissioner A texts Planning Commissioner B about a variance request
on next week's agenda, and they decide over text messaging that they will vote
to deny the request. Planning Commissioner B texts Planning Commissioner C to solicit
his vote. Planning Commissioner C texts back that he also opposes the variances.
Is this a violation?
Basically, yes. Yes, again, the point here is that
text messaging doesn't change anything. It could be over phone calls, it could be
in person, it could be emails. Text messaging just
makes it easier to prove the violation because it's in writing.
So, all right.
Let's talk ethics.
Okay, Municipal Officers and Employees Ethics Act.
Planning commissioners are municipal officers under this act.
Okay, the purpose of this part is— the purposes
of this part are to establish standards of conduct for municipal officers and employees,
and to require these persons to disclose actual or potential
conflicts of interest between their public duties and their personal
interests. Okay.
Definition of appointed officer. So the first question is, are you subject to
the act? And I already told you the answer to this question. Yes, any person
appointed to any statutory officer position
or any other person appointed to any position of employment with the city or with
committee. Da da da da da.
And it says, including appointed officers include but are not limited
to persons serving on special, regular, or full-time committees,
agencies, or boards, whether or not such persons are compensated for their services.
Planning Commission does meet that definition of.
full-time committees, agencies, or boards.
Special, regular, or full-time committees, agencies, or boards. So definitely a regular
committee— it would be a regular committee, agency, or board.
So there you go.
Okay. It is unlawful to disclose or improperly use private, controlled,
or protected information acquired by reason of your position. This is very
unlikely to ever occur, but theoretically possible,
so we're going to talk about it. To further substantially the
officer's personal economic interests, or to secure
special privileges or exemptions for the officer or employee, or for others.
Okay. It is highly unlikely that you will ever come into contact with
private controller protected information under GRAMA.
Theoretically possible, so, But if
you do, obviously you don't use that information to your
personal advantage. That would be unethical.
Okay. These glasses are kind of getting in the way, but it
is unlawful to knowingly receive, accept, take, seek, or solicit directly
or indirectly for the officer or employee or for another
a gift of substantial value, or a substantial
economic benefit tantamount to a gift. That would tend to improperly—
would tend improperly to influence
a reasonable person in the person's position to depart from the faithful and impartial
discharge of the person's duties. The person knows, or that
a reasonable person in that position should know, under the circumstances, primarily for
the purpose of rewarding the person for official action taken. And then
there's the kind of safe harbor Occasional gifts,
$50 and under, are considered presumptively not
in violation. So if—
yeah. So I don't know how often people
are giving gifts to planning commissioners. I suppose at Christmas things happen, like candies and
stuff, cookies. We had the opportunity to go on
a helicopter ride. That could have been considered a gift.
Yeah, I think I am aware of the situation to
which you're referring. Yes, that would be considered
a gift because that person or entity offering the helicopter rides
had business before the Planning Commission and the City Council.
And so it could be considered a reward for services rendered.
And so if it was under $50 worth, value, then you
wouldn't have to report it, and it's presumptively okay. If it's over $50, it doesn't
necessarily mean it's not okay, it's just not presumptively okay.
You get into the gray area. The further from $50 you get,
the less gray it gets. So if somebody offers you something,
you know, $10,000 worth of value, it's pretty clear-cut that that would be a violation.
If somebody offers you $51, probably less clear-cut.
It's probably not a violation. Any more than $50 would be. It's where you
draw the line. So,
you know, there's a, you know, when I was a kid, I hate it now,
but when I was a kid, I was a big fan of Law and Order,
and after I became an attorney, I became less of a fan,
because it just drives you nuts, 'cause you understand the law and why they're
getting it wrong. And, but there was an episode where a
person who was a very wealthy individual, this all takes place
in New York City, uses her influence with the bank, 'cause her business does substantial
banking with this bank, to get
a judge a below-market mortgage interest rate
as a way to bribe him. So I think that would be the def— that
would be like the quintessential substantial economic benefit tantamount to a gift, because she's
not actually directly providing it, she's not actually, they're not, no money
is changing hands, he's just getting a significantly lower interest rate
that's gonna save him, you know, thousands of dollars a month on his mortgage.
So, which is certainly something of value and would be a bribe under any version
of the law. But the issue here is,
would a reasonable person under the circumstances think that the purpose
is for rewarding them of official action taking or trying to influence them?
That's kind of the key language. Rule of thumb, stick to the $50 limit.
You know, use your discretion on what you think occasionally if you
have questions as well. Um, okay, another video. This is
another example of, you know, what not to do. Hey,
Tom, check it out. Norton Construction just sent this over.
Whoa, mama! I love Great Lakes wine.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. You know as well as I do that we are not allowed to accept
gifts over $25 for corruption reasons. We live in a fishbowl and
the public is always watching. But you cannot enjoy this basket. I'm so
sorry. And so to avoid temptation, I'm going to lock it up.
Okay. So apparently in Pawnee,
Indiana, it's $25 is their limit.
But again, I think, you know, again,
under these circumstances where it is a gift that
is probably slightly over $50, it's probably okay.
especially when it's given to a big group of people and not just one individual.
But that was not the one I was thinking of. That comes
up later. Ooh. But in any
event, yes. If somebody
wants to, again, Christmas holiday gifts kind of thing, that's fine. Just,
you know, make sure that they're not like wining and dining you
every week. I don't think that's remotely likely, but.
It is something to be aware of. So it is a responsibility you have under
the Ethics Act. Okay, it is unlawful to use or attempt to use your
official position to further substantially your economic interest
or secure special privileges. This is another,
I don't anticipate this will be a problem, but it's
obvious, and I think it's common sense, but it's something to be aware of.
Okay, let's, Let's go to the next one.
There's a million ways to exploit your power, but have I ever given in to
that temptation? No, never. I'm not that kind of politician. Mr. Parks and Rec Business,
just need to grab a quick hot dog. Sorry about that,
little girl, you can have the next one. I have a moral code and I
never violate it. People look at me and they say, wow, Tom, you are so
pure. You're like a brown Superman with a beard that just stands for
Okay. Yeah, it's, you know, obviously nobody would be that brazen,
hopefully. But yes,
that's an example of what not to do. Okay.
Violations of the Act can be prosecuted criminally.
So that is one of the potential consequences for violation. Depending on the value of
any benefit received, it can be up to a second-degree felony. felony, anywhere from a
B misdemeanor to a second-degree felony. Again, using the $10,000
example, that would be a second-degree felony. Using the $51 example, that would be a
B misdemeanor, and anywhere in between. So just
don't do it, not a problem. Yes?
It's a total hypothetical, but if
someone were to deliver a gift to your porch, say, like in that
It shows up on their desk, then what?
Okay, so if somebody were to deliver a gift that,
you know, clearly has a value, or, you know, you are aware that it has
a value— And felt uncomfortable receiving because it's— That is above $50.
Right. Yeah, then I would
report it. To you? To— Yeah, I mean,
you can reach out to me, reach out to Brandon.
And, you know, we'll advise you on what to do. I think this is
unlikely to occur. I think it's remote. I don't think anyone even knows I'm
on the panel. But if somebody says, you know, here's, you know,
they give you like 2 tickets to the Jazz game and say, all right,
you know, looking forward to seeing you at Planning Commission next week. You know,
if somebody's that brazen, yeah, I mean, just please let us
know. You know, depending on, Depending on what it is exactly,
we would respond appropriately. And like in that scenario, I'd probably
report it to law enforcement, 'cause that's somebody's attempting to bribe a planning commissioner and
take official action. You know, in another
situation where it's a gift basket like there, but it's a really nice one and
you just don't feel comfortable accepting it, then we would deal with that
probably differently. Okay, just curious and adding some interest to
the conversation. Yeah. Yeah, please. If you have questions, feel free to interrupt.
I mean, as much as I love hearing the sound of my own voice,
I'd much prefer to hear the sound of your voices.
So, okay. So,
yeah, so I mean, under the state law, under the Municipal Employees
Ethics Act, the big
thing that you have to do aside from avoiding accepting gifts of large amounts,
is to report certain things that present
a potential conflict of interest. Okay, so again,
in typical legalese, we start with, it is an offense,
i.e., it is a crime, for a planning commission member to
receive or agree to receive compensation for assisting any person or business
entity in any transaction involving the municipality in which the member is an officer,
unless you first file with
the mayor a sworn statement giving the name and address of
yourself, the name and address of the person
or business entity that you'll be assisting,
and a brief description of the transaction. So, you know,
again, this would,
I think, normally occur during a context where somebody has
hired you in the, you know, again, you're laypeople, you're not like
professional planning commissioners where this is your job. You all have
day jobs. And so this would most
likely occur in a situation where somebody has hired you in the course of
your professional duties unrelated to being a planning commissioner, and they want,
in which case you just have to disclose it and then recuse yourself
from any involvement in that action. So that's pretty straightforward.
Under state law, actually, you're only required to disclose it.
Under city law, you're also required to recuse from being
involved in the action. So yeah,
so there's a disclosure form that you can get from the city recorder
if you have that type of, any type of conflicts or any
required disclosures. You should be filling those out, I think, annually.
So. Okay, planning commissioner
who is an officer, director, agent, or employee, or the owner of
a substantial interest in any business entity which is subject to regulation of the municipality,
so in which you are a planning commission member,
you must disclose the position held and the nature and value
of your interest upon first becoming appointed. Again, there's a disclosure form.
So if, for example, you are a business owner and you have a
business, and that business is based in Eagle Mountain, and thus you
have a business license with Eagle Mountain, for example, maybe you own
Crumbl Cookies or something, you own a franchise
there, and you get a business license, and you're subject to regulation by the city
and all that zoning and all that good stuff, then you would just
simply disclose that interest. And if by chance that Crumbl Cookie
franchise had business before the Planning Commission, you would then recuse from any
action related to that. So that's pretty— anytime,
say you're a 50% owner and then you buy out your partner and you become
100% owner, you would disclose that change as well.
Again, we have a form. It says an interest of $2,000 or less need not
be disclosed. So pretty straightforward,
and when in doubt, disclose is always my advice. I get this
question much more often from city council members. But again, my advice
is pretty consistent that, you know, I always advise
to err on the side of disclosure. Like, it may be
something that you don't technically legally have to disclose, but then
it's just like, oh look, if they're disclosing that, then they should, you know,
they'll disclose something that's worse than that.
Planning Commission member who is an officer, director, agent, employee, or owner of substantial interest
in any business which does or anticipates doing business with the municipality in which he's
a Planning Commission member shall publicly disclose to the members of the Planning Commission immediately
prior to any discussion by such body. So we do this every meeting.
We have conflict of interest disclosures. It's right at the
beginning where you would take the opportunity to say,
yes, I own the Crumbl Cookies. That's agenda
item 7B on tonight's agenda, and so I will
be recusing from that. That would be an example.
So that's pretty straightforward. Any questions?
Yes. Mike, if you're
not financially involved with a business, but you're
heavily emotionally involved with the business, would you have to
recuse yourself if it came before the Planning Commission? I guess I
want to understand what you're saying a little more. Like, you really like Crumbl cookies,
and And so— Right, like if it's something that people want to bring to
the city and you really want to support it and promote it,
can you— So again, it requires some sort of either employer-employee
relationship or agency relationship,
like you've contracted with them or you own it in some
fashion, or that would be the type of relationship we're talking about.
So you're saying, man, I really, want Chick-fil-A to come to Eagle
Mountain City, and this business, this Chick-fil-A owner,
is wanting a business license, or whatever. I'm trying to think of something that would
come before the Planning Commission. They're asking for a rezone,
so that they can open up a Chick-fil-A. And you say, I love Chick-fil-A,
and I think every city should have as many Chick-fil-A's as possible,
and I, you know, like, 'cause it's just the best. Their chicken is awesome.
Would that require disclosure? No. Or recusal,
no. It would have to be some sort of, again,
officer, director, agent, so employee,
or owner. Something of that nature where you
have some sort of financial interest. So assisting
them in the proper pathways, and this is who you
need to talk to, this is what you need to do. Again— Involvement, but not
financial. Yeah, I mean, it depends on the nature of that assistance. Are they paying
you for that assistance? Again, because we just covered that a couple slides
ago. If they're not and they're
just saying, hey, I know you're on the Planning Commission, I have some questions about,
you know, the process, you know, I want to locate here,
you know, and you say, oh yeah, you can look at the zoning map,
see what it's zoned for on the city's website, here's how you navigate to there,
and then if you need a rezone, you know, you file an application, you can
get a You can contact Community Development and they'll assist
you with the application process for rezone so that you can get the correct zoning
to open up that Chick-fil-A. And that
type of situation, that's fine. People ask me
legal questions all the time. I always say, I'm not your lawyer, but here's
some friendly advice. Like, this is kind of— this is what you want
to— kinds of things that you would talk to your lawyer about.
So, who is not me.
Drew Corsey, you had a question? Yeah, you may be getting to this,
but familial, like say it was a, I don't know,
brother-in-law that wants to open up the Chick-fil-A.
Yeah, so that
would be, I think, affected under, let's go back to,
Okay. Special privileges.
Yeah, this, where you're talking about—
go back one more slide. There we go.
Getting substantial value, you know, it says again, for the
employee or for another, right, is what it's talking about. So again,
I would disclose that, because it could be
perceived that is a benefit to a family member,
which meets the definition of a benefit for you or another.
Again, somebody related closely to you in this case.
And say, I would— so what I would do is I would not— I would
recuse from that and disclose it. Say, hey, look, this person is my brother or
whatever. You know, I haven't talked to him at all about this,
but I'm going to disclose that, and I'm going to recuse from any consideration.
That's how I would handle that situation specifically,
because I do think that that is potentially problematic. Yeah,
just for the record, I don't have any family in Eagle Mountain, but just asking.
In that case, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Somebody moves
here, you never know. Yeah, I was saying, at some point we've all fallen for
the trick. Question on, in that
context, like, so there's a formal disclosure form
that you would submit ahead of time, but like if it's just—
In theory, there should be an annual disclosure that you're filing. Oh,
okay. So if that is not occurring, we can make sure that that does
occur going forward. Okay. I have— I don't—
I haven't seen the annual one. I don't know. Did you file a disclosure form
when you first were appointed? I have to— I'm pretty sure I did. Yeah,
okay. So yeah, I'll have to look at it whether or not it's just the
City Council has to update it annually if possible. Okay. I know, I mean,
it's clear that you have to update it if things change. Yeah. But it may
just be that you do it when you're first appointed. Okay. I know the City
Council has to do it every year, but that may not actually apply to you.
So, okay.
Okay, again, any personal interest or investment which
creates conflict between you and your public duties, is disclosed in
this meeting, or, you know, in the next meeting, and you
also disclose it in a sworn statement to the mayor.
So again, we have that at the beginning of every meeting, any conflict of
interest, and routinely people say no, 'cause that's usually the case.
And yes, but in the event that somebody says yes,
you would describe the conflict, you'd fill out the form, submit it, okay, and give
it to Brandon. He'd make sure the mayor gets it. Thank you.
Okay. In addition to any criminal penalties that we've previously discussed,
violation of disclosure requirements mandates
expulsion from the Planning Commission. I mean, it seems pretty self-explanatory.
Don't break the ethical rules.
It also— if any action taken in violation of disclosure requirements
could potentially— the action could potentially voided.
So we just want to steer clear of
any of that. So my advice is, when in doubt, disclose,
disclose, disclose. I think that's the safest course.
If you say, all right, you know, we have a rezone application,
and, you know, my family
member owns property in that area
that's being rezoned. They don't really have any plans to do anything differently,
but, you know, I mean, like,
anything as innocuous as that, I would say that's probably not legally required to be
disclosed, but, you know, so if you have any questions,
should I disclose it or not, my advice is always just disclose
it. I mean, anybody's gonna think, oh yeah, you know.
If you disclose and you don't, strictly speaking, have to disclose, then you can
still still vote if you want to, and we can have that discussion about
whether or not disclosure is strictly speaking required,
but you still wanna vote and participate 'cause that's your duty as a member of
the Planning Commission. And that's fine,
that does happen. But again,
in that situation, I wouldn't think you would be required to disclose, in my opinion.
So I would say you could still vote even if you disclosed it. Yeah,
I just had a follow-up question on that. So if you had, like, in an
agenda, Somebody, as we're doing your conflict
of interest, if somebody notes that they have a conflict for a particular item,
what's the proceed— can they be part of the discussion,
or— So my preference is that if you
think your answer to that question might be yes, is to contact me in advance
of the meeting, and we can have a discussion not in a public setting.
Okay, the nature of— Yeah, so we can have an attorney-client
Okay. And about the issue.
Okay. Is that— I don't know if anybody's had a situation like that
come up on— So— I've never had that situation come up on a meeting that
I've attended, but it's good to know individually. Yeah, I mean, if, for example,
like something like UDOT comes in and they are doing something and
it actually relates to your responsibilities with UDOT, then yeah.
Okay. Sounds good. We'll have that discussion.
Okay. Okay, so this is— now we're getting into city code.
So again, here, this again, this is going to your question a little bit
about siblings. But basically it says, for purposes of this chapter, an official
has a conflict of interest if the official knows or has reason to know that
the official or a parent of the official or the official's spouse, sibling, or other
member of the same household, agent, principal, client, employer, or employee,
is required to disclose a conflict of interest by the requirements of the
Municipal Officers and Employees Ethics Act. And then adds additional requirements.
So again, so getting back to the sibling question, under city code
you would have to disclose. I think under state law you would have to as
well. But there's a— it's,
I think, crystal clear under city code. Code has an ownership
interest in a business having matters under proper consideration.
Has an ownership interest in property within Eagle Mountain
City for which zoning, conditional use, or development approvals are under consideration.
Represents as agent, professional services contractor, other advisor,
individual, or organization under consideration before
the Planning Commission. I'm seeing that I copied and pasted this from
the city code. and it's driving me nuts because there's no Oxford comma.
But yes.
Has an ownership interest in a business or property that has been issued
a business license, is a place of business, or otherwise operates a business offering or
providing goods, products, or services in Eagle Mountain, or uses or develops property.
So again, this is all kind of, I think, common sense. If you
have a financial interest in something that has Or somebody that has
business before the Planning Commission, then you should
disclose and recuse. Again, if it's
your primary residence and it's rezoned, that's an exception. But otherwise,
if it's a rental property that's getting rezoned, then yes,
you have to disclose that. It's a business that
has whatever business before the Planning Commission.
You have to disclose, and under our code, if you have to disclose, again,
if you're required to disclose, then you have to recuse as well.
So again, has an ownership interest in property other than that of a primary residence
that might enjoy direct and immediate financial benefit or suffer direct economic harm
by zoning, conditional use, or development approvals.
So by even if the land is not actually owned by you. So for example.
So if somebody wants to open up a gravel pit close to your residence,
you know, 1,000 feet away, like the bare minimum away
that it has to be, or somebody wants to open some
sort of commercial business that might be considered,
you know, something that would devalue your property, sexually oriented business,
for example. Then,
and it's not your primary residence, right, then that would— then you'd
have to disclose and recuse. So you have a business next to this,
you own a property that you, you know, whatever, in a business
that's next to this sexually oriented business that wants approval,
then your business is probably going to go down in value if that gets
approved. So that would be an example, you know,
but the reverse is also true. You know,
you own a car repair business, and somebody
wants approval of a car lot right next to it or something. Theoretically, you know,
something that where there's some sort of synergy there. I don't know, that was just
an example I came up with off the top of my head. But anywhere,
you know, something where you're gonna get some sort of synergy from, for your business,
where this other business, you know, that would be an example
of where you would disclose and recuse. Yeah, so again, I mean,
this next one is common sense, I hope.
Has an agreement with the party seeking approval that would financially benefit the public official
if such approval were granted. Okay, yeah, so that's
a bribe, so don't do that.
Hypothetical 1. Planning Commissioner A goes
to a planning conference to receive training on his duties. Company 1 invites Planning Commissioner
A A to dinner and pays. Company 1 has business before
the Planning Commission. The cost of the Planning Commissioner's dinner is $40. Is this a
violation of the Ethics Act?
No. No. That one's pretty easy. Again, without more,
you know, if they're taking you to dinner every night for like a month,
that's different than what we're talking about here.
Again, hypothetical 2, it's the same facts except the dinner costs $75.
Is this a violation of the Ethics Yes, maybe. I like your answer.
As a lawyer, it depends is like my favorite thing to say.
I would say it's probably not a violation, but you're outside the safe harbor.
So I would recommend against doing that, because,
you know, again, where do you draw the line? Is a $75 dinner
a violation? Is that the type of thing that a reasonable person would not faithfully,
you know, impartially discharge their duties as a planning commissioner?
Probably not. Is $100 that number?
$150? $200? Where's the number? I don't know. All I know is
that the further we drift from $50, the more in trouble we're getting.
So my advice is don't do it. Order something
that costs less than $50 so that Brian will be correct.
You're not violating— you know, that would be a violation for going over $75.
You know, we don't want to even get— we don't want to get near that.
So that's my advice. Thank you. Don't do it. Okay.
Planning Commissioner B owns 25% of Company 2.
Company B has business before the Planning Commission. Does Planning Commissioner B have any obligations
under state or city ethics laws? If so, what are those obligations?
They have a part, they have an ownership in the business, so, but I can't
remember I don't know if there was a 25% or 50%, but I mean,
yeah, I would disclose it either way. The language is substantial interest.
Okay. So I would say 25% is substantial.
Okay. So I
would disclose it. Okay?
And you should be disclosing that when you're appointed,
before there's any business before the Planning Commission.
On the night of the Planning Commission, you would then disclose
it again when we say, do you have any conflict of interest? And you say,
yes, I have conflict of interest on item 7A.
And then you would recuse from that item. Thank you.
Okay. All right. So now this is
a new addition to our training, standards for civil discourse. We have not observed
any issues here, thank goodness, but it is something to be trained on and is
related to ethics. Okay, so this
is from, direct from our city code. It is in the chapter on
city council, but is applicable to, by its terms,
elected officials, members of city boards and commissions, and employees in public, in any
city public meetings. So that would include planning commissioners in a planning commission
meeting. Okay, the following standards are intended
to encourage and require Eagle Mountain City Members of
city boards and commissions to meet obligations of civil
discourse to each other and to the public and comply with the requirement
of a statute that just says you
need to create rules for standards of civil discourse. Elected officials,
members of city boards and commissions, and employees are expected to make mutual and
firm commitments to adhere to these standards. Okay.
So what are they? Conduct and language that
is condescending, uncivil, abrasive, abusive, hostile, or obstructive
impedes the fundamental goal of participating in civil discourse and public processes and
the rational, peaceful, and efficient resolution of decisions and
is a violation of this standard. Such conduct tends
to delay and often to deny resolution of issues in the public interest.
So again, I have not observed an issue in the Planning Commission in
relation to this. So, but it is
something to be aware of that we should— again, I think this is common sense,
but we should be civil in the way that we deal with each other,
we deal with the public, we deal with staff, et cetera.
Elected and appointed officials, and again, planning commissioners are
appointed officials, and city employees should exhibit courtesy,
candor, and cooperation in dealing with each other and the public and in
the administration of the city. Yeah, I think that's pretty straightforward.
So don't try to lie or deceive people. You know,
so, and treat people with courtesy
and respect. So elected officials,
members of city boards and commissions, and employees shall not, without an adequate factual
basis, attribute to other persons improper motives, purpose,
or conduct. Each person affiliated— So again, that's,
Again, don't call someone a liar unless you have the goods
to back it up. So if you're gonna,
you know, you can always assume that they just misunderstand
or that they're wrong, not that they're intentionally fabricating things,
unless you know that they are or have at least good evidence to suggest that
they are. Each person affiliated with
the city should avoid hostile, demeaning, Or humiliating conduct in words
and written and oral communications. Neither written submissions nor oral statements or conduct should disparage
the integrity, intelligence, morals, ethics, or personal behavior of others.
Again, you know I think this is common
sense kind of stuff. But again, I have not observed any issues in
relation to this in the planning commission, so I wouldn't be you
know too concerned. Just keep it in mind. You know again, we're going to.
Treat people with respect, you know, courtesy,
and I think everything else takes care of itself.
So any questions?
Questions? Okay, that's it.
Great. Thank you, Marcus, for putting that together
for us, and thanks for having some good comments and questions.
It is 6:15. Next on our agenda Is just a
preview of tonight's agenda.
If we want to do that for a few minutes before we take
a break, let's see. So tonight's agenda—I
don't know.
Oh, Vince, I oh, I don't know if there's anything that
you want to. preemptively review
for the 2 agenda items that you have for
tonight's policy session, or if you just wanna wait until then.
Yeah, not necessarily, unless you have specific questions,
but. Okay. Commissioners,
I would suggest we can wait to ask those questions during the
policy session. Is that okay? Yep. All right,
okay. I see the discussion item. I guess this
is a discussion agenda number 8 on the agenda later. I guess
we can just wait and have that discussion then. Is there— That would be the
best. Is that a good time to do that? Okay, perfect. Okay, well, with that
said, we'll go ahead and if there's no objections, we'll go ahead and end our
working session and we'll start back promptly
at 6:30.
Okay, it is 6:30 PM on
Tuesday, September 8th. We'll go ahead and welcome individuals
for our Planning Commission meeting, our policy session.
We'll go ahead and get started. And the—
on our agenda, go ahead and if you'll stand with me and join in the
Pledge of Allegiance. I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America,
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America
and to the republic for which it stands, one nation under
God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you for that. Well, next on our agenda item is our declaration
of conflicts. We'll start with Commissioner Jensen.
None. Commissioner DiCorsi. None.
Commissioner Hess has none. Commissioner Strom. None. Commissioner Allen.
None. Commissioner Fried. None. Okay.
Next is a review of our August 25th Planning
Commission meeting minutes. Any notes in
your review that need to be pointed out or adjusted?
Okay, I'll entertain a motion for
those Planning Commission meetings minutes.
Chair, I move that we approve the August 25th, 2026 Planning Commission
minutes as presented. I'll second that. Okay, we have a motion
made for approval by Commissioner Allen, followed by a
second by Commissioner Strong. Any discussion?
Okay. We'll proceed with our vote. We'll start with Commissioner DiCorsi.
Yes. Commissioner Hess is yes. Commissioner Strum?
Yes. Commissioner Allen? Yes. And Commissioner Freeh? Yes.
Okay, thank you. All right,
um, next is a status report. Is there any,
any status or any items that need to be mentioned
from city staff? Um, just a
couple of things. We do have the
APA Planning Conference this week. There's a few of you who have been registered
for that. I did want to let you know of a few applications
that, uh, kind of the outcome of a few applications
that did come to the city council last week.
The Gateway Park Phase 3 application
was approved. That was the
preliminary plat up by,
and I always forget, I never can keep the name of this in my head,
up by Spring Run Plaza A
and B. So, and then there was,
There was the Pinnacles rezone that was
proposed to rezone the strip of commercial
land on— what was that,
on Aviator? Aviator. That failed.
It was denied by the council.
And then the retaining
wall code also went forth, and that was, that was
successful. It was approved by the council. So that's what I
have for you today. Thank you,
Brandon, for those updates and for your staff and all they do.
Next, our agenda item number 7 is our action advisory items.
We'll go ahead and start with item 7A,
a public hearing An ordinance for this Eagle Mountain,
Utah— Eagle Mountain City updating the culinary water impact
fee facility plan. This will be presented by City Engineer
Vince Hoag.
Okay, hold on till I get the right screen up there.
Can we get full screen, whichever that is?
Sorry, technical difficulties here. I'm getting all my notes on
the screen that you're seeing and getting the PowerPoint on my laptop here,
so it should be swapped.
See if I can figure that out.
Let's try
that.
Still swapped. But I guess we can do it this way rather
than delay, but— Upwards is display settings.
There we go. There you go.
Thank you. All right.
Yeah, I'm here today to talk about the culinary
water IFFP update. The update is
from last year's 2025 version,
which was the most recent version.
In in the course of working at Eagle Mountain City,
I've noticed that there's a lot of changes happening in the city. I'm sure
you guys see it too, and change is happening fast. And so because
of some of the changes that have happened, we've felt it was necessary to
take that IFFP and do an update to it.
There are several reasons for that. We'll get into more of the details
here in a minute.
One of the main reasons we started looking at
doing an update to this was a new master plan.
This is for the Talons Cove Spring Run area. Brandon was just talking about
that. We're already getting commercial applications up in that area for
development. You can see Walmart kind of in the lower left
there and SR 73 on the south side of the map. This is
all part of the mine that's up there that Hadco
owns and runs.
The plan is to eventually build this all out with commercial,
institutional, and at this point it's It's all a
master-planned area, but the assumption
was when we did our original IFMP was that this project area was 30
years out or more before they would finish mining in that area and
actually start building. But the reality is we're already getting applications
in for kind of the south end and the west end that's not
part of the mine itself that is part of this master plan. And so we—
We thought, let's take a step back and include this area. It's a large area
of land. Let's include it in our planning for the future.
The next big piece of change was our
SR-73 Central Utah Pipeline.
This is a pipeline— Central Utah actually provides
about half of our culinary water, and we have a contract
to supply a lot more of our culinary water in the
future. Our existing pipeline from central Utah comes up Pony Express
from a pump station down right inside Saratoga
Springs, and that one is basically at capacity at this point.
And so if we want more of the central Utah water that we have contracted,
we need a new pipeline. Now, up on
73, right on the east end of the kind of the blue line there,
Central Utah has a big terminal, what they call their terminal reservoir,
and I think it's 20 million gallons with room for expansion in
that area. They pump water to there,
and then it's the city's responsibility to take the water from there and
get it the rest of the way into the city. And so part
of that project will be a pump station there next to their reservoirs, and then
the The blue line and the purple lines that you see are options for routes
that that pipeline is going to take from that pump station into the city.
As we did our 30% design, those costs came in.
We had a cost in there in the original IFFP, but the
more detailed cost estimate came in higher than we anticipated.
Part of that was because we upsized the pipeline for additional
future growth and the potential for additional Central Utah water if that
ever comes available, so we only have to build this pipeline once and not
have to run parallel lines. So we're we're looking to the future. We're planning for
the future, but because of that, the cost came in higher.
Okay, the other thing is that we have
several wells that are under construction right now. We have
a tank that's under construction.
In the Scarlet Ridge area down south.
And based on the pricing trends that we saw from those bids and
from the contractors coming in and building those,
we realized that the cost for future tanks
and wells in this IFFP were a little on
the low end. And so we decided to bump those up so that
the impact fees that we would collect, which will be based on,
on the IFFP cost estimates, would reflect the
real-world costs.
And then the bottom line for culinary water, and these numbers
are different from what you saw, I think, if you looked at the original PowerPoint
that was attached. I updated these numbers because
they didn't reflect exactly what was in the plans, but these numbers do
reflect now. So we went from about $73.2 million to
$109.1 million just for the culinary water infrastructure over the next
5 years. So that's a big gap, which means
the IFFP update was, was needed for
sure. And the whole point of this
is so that the new growth coming in, they'll pay the impact fees and those
costs aren't put on the residents who are already here.
They will be a cost to any new home that's built.
And then with that,
open it up for any questions you guys have.
Commissioner, is there a plan— let's say we don't
have the growth. I mean, we probably will, but something happens
and the growth slows way down and we don't have that growth to help pay
for that that we need from those impact fees. Because maybe it
slows way down due to COVID, another COVID or something, you know,
happening. Is there a plan for
how to, like, to fund that if we don't have those impact fees? So yes
and no. I mean,
the— what happens if there's not as much growth
as we anticipated typically means we don't have to build the projects as
fast as we anticipated. Either, and so in the
end it kind of balances out. It's not a one-to-one relationship.
There's a lot of factors there, obviously, and getting the Central Utah into the city—it
will need to happen, I think, either way.
But yeah, they they do kind of balance out in the end. And then the
rest of the question is probably more on the financial side, which I'm not as
familiar with. But a lot of our bigger projects were were.
Getting bonding for. And the bonding,
kind of the backing for the bonding, they don't rely on the impact fees.
They are actually looking at other income that's more consistent,
such as our water rates and our sewer rates and those kind of things,
to back that bond. And so,
yeah, yeah.
Commissioner Strong. Yeah, just more of a question.
You said that they're pumping water into a reservoir,
and then we have to pump it from the reservoir to here? Yes.
Okay, and I assume they're pumping it out of a well, is that correct?
Uh, their sources vary. A lot of it comes from Deer
Creek Reservoir and Provo River, and then a lot of it comes from
wells, uh, in Orem and Vineyard area.
Oh, okay. I, I did see that it got over that far,
so it could be coming out of The Strawberry Aqueduct
or one of those places, right? Yep. OK.
Other questions for Vince at this time?
OK. Thank you, Vince, for that presentation.
This is a public hearing for this agenda item, so it is
6:43. We'll go ahead and open our public hearing for
agenda item 7A.
Anybody in the audience wishing to make comments for this item?
Anything received online? Okay. All right.
We will— let's go ahead and end the public hearing, seeing no comments. It is
6:43. And with the
public hearing over, any discussion amongst
the commission on this item?
Commissioner DiCorsi. Yeah, I just
would like to kind of recognize or thank staff for being proactive and looking
ahead at costs and hopefully taking
into account, you know, a lot of future growth as we
plan these projects. I don't think it's ever as painful the first time as it
is to go back and try to do it once everything's built in. So I'm
in favor of it.
Noted, thank you. Any other discussion or
questions? OK, if no further discussion,
I'll entertain a motion on agenda item 7A. Chair,
I move that we forward a positive recommendation to City Council for item
7A as presented. I'll second
that. Okay, okay, we have a motion presented by
Commissioner Allen to forward a positive recommendation on this agenda item,
followed by a second from Commissioner Strong.
Any need for final discussion or clarification?
Okay, hearing no further discussion, we'll go
ahead and start the voting. I will begin the voting. Commissioner Hess is yes.
Commissioner Strong? Yes. Commissioner Allen? Yes.
Commissioner Fried? Yes. And Commissioner DiCorsi? Yes.
Okay, thank you. That vote passes with 5 votes,
um, or that motion passes with 5 votes.
Okay, moving on to our next agenda item, 7B.
Again, this will be presented, this is a public hearing as well,
for wastewater master plan and the wastewater
impact fee. Facility Plan, again presented
by Vince Hoag, our city engineer.
So a note on this one, we did update our master plan in addition to
the IFFP because there were enough changes on the wastewater side
that we felt it was a good idea to do both. And so we're bringing
both before you today.
You'll see these slides are very similar
to The ones we just went through, so similar reasons
that we're going through this updating costs, adding additional areas.
Again, Spring Run Talons Cove area.
This one impacted the wastewater not just in
that specific area, but it also required several upgrades
in the the ranches parkway. Roadway to
get the wastewater from here down to Pony Express. And all,
all of this actually ends up in the Temponoga Special Service District treatment plant.
And so yeah, there were, there were pretty significant changes that needed to happen because
of this area in our existing system.
This one, our wastewater treatment plant expansion,
we're at 60% design on that. We're taking our
wastewater treatment plant from 2.4 million gallons of treated water
a day up to a capacity of 8 million gallons of
treated water per day. So that's a significant
increase. Again, that was in the original IFFP,
but now that we've reached the 60% design, again with
increasing costs, we thought, well, it's increased enough that
we should go back to the master plan and IFFP. And update those there.
The other part of that is our east trunk line, which this figure,
it's a little hard to see because it's small, but on the far east side
there's a red dotted line which is our east trunk line. That one
is at a 30% design also.
Our trunk line that currently goes down Pony Express right now is
really close to being at capacity, and so any additional
growth growth anywhere along Pony Express or on the north end of the
city, it won't be able to tie into Pony Express.
We, we need a new trunk line, and the best route for that
trunk line we determined was on the east side of the city, and that
will tie into that same wastewater treatment plant. But at
30% design, we updated the costs on that one too.
And then same thing, not talking
about wells and tanks like we were with culinary water,
but just installation costs for sewer
lines and those kind of things, updating pricing
in general as those costs rise.
And the bottom line on this way— on this one, and most of the jump
in costs was our wastewater treatment plant as we refined that cost,
but it went from $193 million to $259
million.
Any questions on this one? Questions for Vince from
the commission? Commissioner Corsi.
I probably should have asked this on the first one. Talons Cove,
I, I'm not familiar with that. I guess associated with Spring Run,
that has nothing to do with the Talons Cove, like Saratoga Golf
Course? It does not. Okay. It's just kind of a name that we have for
that area. I think that's the name of the pit, if I remember right.
Oh, right. Okay. I should know. Okay.
Then as kind of a follow-up, it looked like maybe— is
there a little bit of that area that's also within Saratoga Springs jurisdiction?
And is there any coordination on sort of where that Wastewater
or culinary water go? Right. This development is
right on the line between Eagle Mountain and Saratoga
Springs, yes. And we have had discussions because there is a part on
the northeast corner where it would actually flow easier
as far as wastewater goes to go into the Saratoga Springs side
than it would to the Eagle Mountain side. And so we've started some discussions.
I think that part of it is far enough out in years that we have
time to figure that out. But yeah, there will be a lot
of coordination for transportation and possibly sewer and culinary water
in that area. Great, thank you. Yep.
Other questions? Okay.
All right, thank you, Vince, for that presentation.
This, again, this is a public
hearing for agenda item 7B. We'll go at
6:50 PM. We'll go ahead and open that public hearing.
Any individuals wishing to make comments?
Any online or anything submitted through the website
or anything like that? Okay. All right. Hearing no comments
for the public hearing, we'll go ahead and end our public hearing at 6:51.
And any discussion?
Okay. Hearing no discussion, I will propose
a— make a motion. I make
a motion to forward a positive recommendation to City Council regarding Agenda Item 7B.
I'll second that. Okay.
Commissioner Hess, Made a motion to forward
a positive recommendation on this agenda item, followed by a second
from Commissioner DeCourcy. Any final questions?
Okay, we'll proceed with our vote. We'll begin with Commissioner Strong.
Yes. Commissioner Allen. Yes. Commissioner Freeh. Yes.
Commissioner DeCourcy. Yes. And Commissioner Hess
is yes. Okay, that Motion passes
with 5 votes, and that ends
our policy session or the act.
Sorry, the action advisory item 7.
Thank you for your time, and then we'll move to agenda item number 8: a
discussion on agriculture rural lot large
lot zone, and this will be
presented by Robert. Thank you, Chair. Chair and members of the Commission,
you should have received today, I don't know if you had a chance to see
it, a supplementary email that is an adjunct to the staff report,
and it has within its confines simply a chart which I'm
going to show you tonight again in this PowerPoint. The PowerPoint,
as you received it, I might have noted in my report, I thought I did,
but it didn't have quite everything as far as the historic zone
Shown as slides within it, and I've got a few of those to add
that I have added. Excuse me, to the to the PowerPoint you'll see.
So finally, I don't know how many years it's been actively
attempted, but at the table we have
a discussion, as you noted, for the with the idea central to
trying to add a zoning district to the Cedar
Pass Ranch community. The best records that I could find once upon a
time suggested that upon annexation originally of the project or
the community, that no zoning assignment was actually given to it
specifically. I couldn't find anything in the ordinance. I couldn't find any kind of mapped
exhibits. That's been a long time ago.
But others have struggled to try and identify the zone,
if there was one, that was assigned to the project. The question mark being,
well, was it ever given one or was it a carryover from the county's presumably
RA-5 zone that one of our planners in office who worked at the county
believes it to have been. We have in attendance tonight representatives
from the community, from the HOA, and a committee that was
put together to help craft or suggest ideas
for the creation of a zone.
The effort has been ongoing now for some months,
and staff, I wish to give great credit to the
persons seated in this chamber this evening and listening in,
in the case of one, and others who had a central
and strong role in trying to put together what they believed would
be appropriate for their community to have in the way of zoning.
Recognizing that in many instances in this city, large developments
have been given their own set of standards, almost like planned unit developments
by virtue of master development plans and associated agreements. The ranches being in this area
characteristic of that, albeit that one's expired. You look at that plan,
it was gigantic. It covered most of the northern part of the city at one
time, and the agreement that went with it is about 328 pages
long. This effort is
something that we are hoping to get comment on tonight, especially of course
the codes. Started with the historic zone,
and then we were also given an understanding that it would be nice to
have a zone that would be applicable to other parts of the city. So not
only Cedar Pass, but could be used elsewhere if need be.
Given the two different directions that that created, or vectors with
this zoning effort, then in front of you this evening are
both amendments as proposed: the
historical and this agricultural rural large lot one that we have.
As part of this discussion only recently been tackling,
especially the committee's been tackling— excuse me.
In any event, the idea is that the Commission could look at this,
weigh in with some comments. This is not a decision-making effort this evening,
but give suggestions to the Cedar
Pass folks and staff on what kinds of things you think would
be appropriate to maybe take away or add to or whatever. whatever you wish to
voice. And ultimately, of course, as you know,
past the point of this meeting and on to council, then this matter will
come back to you, presumably in about October, for formal action,
hearing, et cetera, and then on to council for the same.
I think you already are well aware, of course, of where Cedar Pass is,
and generally speaking, the magnitude to the project site.
I keep calling it that, sorry. Too many site plans in
the past. This is the chart that
I'm gonna come back to in just a
bit. In your packet, you had the agricultural
large lot zone standards just
for showing tonight.
Here and here and so forth. And then I
added after the packet was crafted this,
that's extracted from the historic zone.
And in so doing thought, well, easier than going through those slide by
slide and to help guide the discussion, let's create a chart.
So we're gonna go back to that. Compare and contrast.
There are a few more differences than I thought originally.
Also, I want to take time now to ask
if you're okay with it, as kind of a co-presentation, to have
those folks that are here or their designated representative
rise to the rostrum and maybe introduce themselves and give
a little backstory on their efforts and anything else they'd
like to say about this adventure. And then I'll jump back in.
Uh, yeah, I don't— Commissioners, I don't think that's a problem. We okay that?
Okay, sure.
Yeah.
Well, good evening, Commissioners. I'm Dylan Anderson.
Um, I've been in your seat. I was a commissioner in 2007, uh,
2017. So I appreciate all your efforts.
When I was a commissioner, I was able to be a part of hearing developers
come and give a presentation like this to try to bounce
ideas off, to try to help in the process.
And so as a part of this,
my history with the city runs really deep because
I came out here before there was a city. I came out here in '94
looking for property for my family, specifically for my
wife who wanted horse property. And so my
wife, Danae, had the vision that this would be a place that
we would want to raise our family. And so Cedar Pass Ranch
was the development before there was a city. And so
fortunately we got in early and we were able to build our home in '99.
So I've seen a lot of the growth. I've seen all
the growth and the pains that we've gone through as a city.
But we love it here and
wouldn't change being here. When I
am the HOA president and when
we found out the situation with the zoning, And in
conversation with Robert Hobbs, we felt like, how can we help
in this process? And excited
to learn, not knowing the challenge, but excited to learn that
we could be a part of it. Then we discovered, wow, what a challenge.
And so in order to work through this, we decided to
pull together some really smart
people within our subdivision who could help and know the history.
And we put together a committee to help to do this. And the
committee was John and Susan Morandi with Mayor Burningham,
Jeff Myers, and myself, working sometimes
weekly but monthly with Robert over
a process of hardcore 10 months.
But this has been almost 2 and a half years in the works.
So this is hopefully finding a finish line
in the process. Why don't you add a few things if you like, Susan?
Yeah, I just want to add that I think the intention of— You can,
yeah, if you'll step up, yeah. Hi. Tell us who
you are. Susan Morandi. Okay, thanks. And how long have you been here? How long
have I been here? Yeah. 9 years.
I've been in Eagle Mountain 9 years. now. So, um,
it was— it started as part of the HOA process to— when
we were years ago looking to rewrite— is when rewrite
our CC&Rs is when we found out we weren't zoned. I did the research.
I know we weren't zoned. So,
um, and the city is kind of— we kind of worked with them trying to
figure it out and A few years ago, we were approached
and asked to help create zones, and it was— we were
tasked with that, and we set up a committee to do it. And it was
important for everybody to keep a zone with what the residents are
currently doing now in Cedar Pass Ranch. So we were working along
that process, and as we were nearing
the end, then we were asked if we wouldn't mind sharing our zone language
that we created to use in other parts of the city. And we're like,
well, we're unique. We don't have the same
things in other parts, you know, in our development that are
going to be in other parts of the city, especially the equestrian component
that— and the trails. That's pretty unique to Cedar Pass Ranch,
and that's why people are there. So, so that's just a little
bit of background that we We separated it out into
the ARLL zone, and then we wanted to kind of keep ours
more of a historical zone. So, and that's where we're at today.
Yeah. So as we were reviewing this, I tell you,
we sure learned a lot. Robert taught us a lot.
City Attorney helped us work through a lot of the language.
We actually looked through a lot of the city zones. that are our neighbors.
The historical part we started to realize
a few months ago was if you drive—
we're a very young city. Where would our
history be with our city? Well, it's in where
our roots are. And our roots were Cedar Pass Ranch
and the ranches and the master development plan. Which when
I saw that, I was like, man, this is a grand plan.
And wow, how many times did that change? I saw every change.
And I have been here so many times to witness it.
It was a great idea, but it had to be adapted over time.
And when I think about, well, if you drive to Park City, there are some
really strict zoning in Park City. You can't
touch downtown Park City. You can't touch downtown Provo.
You can't change a lot of the history of the older towns.
And so here, I would hope that the city would be thinking, what are
our roots? And I remember how
Eagle Mountain City was advertised, and it
was footage of Cedar Pass Ranch and the ranches.
Please come where there's open space, where you
can grow and you can have animals. And that
was for years. It was pictures of all of our properties,
which was great.
But we feel like that's also the roots of the city. And so we would
hope that what we work
towards in recognizing it as a historical zone,
that the Planning Commission, but also the city council members who
we've actually spent a lot of time talking with them to get their input so
that we could do a lot of the
legwork, a lot of the hard processing.
And so right towards the tail end, there was some discussion
about, you know, other parts of the city are going to be developed where we
would like to do large lots too. Can we take this language and use
it there? We're like, well, do what you want with it. I think that's great,
but still there are some significant differences, which is what
Susan's referred to and which will— Robert's hopefully going to be able
to go through those key differences so that you see the benefits of both.
And we're willing to field any questions you have and try to
help you through this.
Okay, do you— I guess at this point Just an open discussion
between commissioners, or do you? Is there more that you want to get
through to present before we ask questions? Yes.
Okay. Thank you, Chair, for that question.
My aspiration is that we would do just as was
kind of just noted, and be sort of a team approach. And I can present
a little bit more, and then if there's discussion or questions that either parties,
self, staff, or the co-applicants,
if you will, could be involved in that Q&A,
et cetera. And anecdotally,
this is— it sounded like from what I've been told in the past when I
started here that this effort has hit and miss over
a long span of time, a few times. I don't know how many times.
To get it to this stage finally is like
crossing the Olympics, you know, little end ribbon tape in the 100-meter
dash. So regardless of the outcome,
our hope is that we'll get a recommendation that council will do
something with this, that it won't fall by the wayside. That would be tragic.
So now, in looking at this chart, I think the understanding
that you heard was that it sounds like the Cedar Pass folks, by and large—
and this was presented to them at an HOA meeting that they had back in
May, as I know in Report would probably like to preserve the character
of what they had run with this most of this time, which is the historic
zone. But as need be, of course, would be
open necessarily to what the city might decide if we go with,
for example, this other ARLL zone. I'll call it for short.
So starting at the top, these columns
give you an indication that. There's kind of
a different purpose statement, obviously, with each. We can kind of skip
that, I suppose. But one of the— going down
to the first yellow highlighted item on the left-hand side,
the leftmost column under provision,
there is a nonconforming lot threshold
callout. And then there should
also be down below that a size minimum for
lots. One of the key issues in that
project has been the desire of the residents,
it sounds like to me, at least of the committee and the HOA, to preserve
a 5-lot minimum, recognizing there are a few lots that are under that threshold that
are necessarily grandfathered or legally nonconforming, as we would say,
and that any future lots that would be derived
from properties, if there are any ever, from existing
Platted lots would be at least 5 acres in size and preserve 5 acres
for the parent property. The contrasting
ARLL zone suggestion is
to allow for 3 acres as a minimum,
and it grandfathers lots under 3 acres.
And I don't know how much you want me to go over this verbally.
Or if you want me to let you read, Chair, you might just define that
for me here. But a couple of callouts that are of note: commercial
equestrian operations are noted as being a special
use opportunity in the historic zone,
I'll call it. And bear in mind, as a reminder,
which you know, but in case it's needing to be said,
our special uses in code may or may not yet be
entered or codified. There are special uses
that are defined. There's a few standards, and there's some that are maybe referenced but
aren't— there's no standards given to them. They're basically an
allowed use as long as you meet these certain standards. They're kind of like the
conditional use permit became in Utah some years ago versus other cities and
states— other states, we'll say. Sorry.
When it comes to the ARL zone, as noted
there, that's a deleted provision or opportunity. In other words, it's prohibited.
You get down to ag structures, et cetera, you have the
opportunity for indoor riding arenas in the historic zone,
except that it's omitted, disallowed basically from the
RLL zone. Now there
are some business opportunities the RLL zone allows for, adding farm stands
and separate agricultural sales activities.
And as it says, a special use path for commercial equestrian operations
is not there.
We have a little issue on the ARL zone language.
It's called out on the top of that That's a column.
But I wanna skip on down to something of more substance,
basically. Storage and shipping containers. So the
historic zone recognizes that there are some out there.
I don't know how many, I haven't tried to inventory them. At least
one. And that those can be allowed one
at a time, looks like, per lot. But in the
ARL zone, that's omitted as a subsection,
basically getting your back to just not gonna allow for them.
And so whatever's there could be grandfathered, and we can— bearing in mind,
let me back up one quick step, I'm sorry. We have
a legal nonconforming use section in our code,
germane to any other city or county pretty much anymore.
But it's pretty short.
And at one time the goal was to revamp it,
to give it a little more meat, if you will. I looked
at what Provo had and other places. Theirs is pretty long and— excuse
me— but it has a lot of good stuff to it, in it. But there's
always been a desire from staff's point of view to make sure that anything
that's out there that post the adoption of any of these items
codes or anything else. That where people would like to
apply for grandfather rights to say, we believe this was legal to begin with and
we've carried it along all through this, this time period, and now that
the zoning's changed, we'd like to have it recognized formally as being, quote, grandfathered,
then we, using what our code is now or something better in the future,
should be in a position to do that. We need to respect
people's property rights. And so we would ask for any kind of information that they
have to give us, and there's a laundry list to give you, like things that
are commonly used for that. But, but we would then create a record,
and maybe that's a, in the future, a free application that they go
for, you know, and file online. But in any event, it would be something to
protect them and their property rights, whether it's a situation or
some other nonconformance. And then that's to the best of our knowledge. So if there
were countervening evidence, it would come forward and we would factor that
in someday. In any event, that's the goal,
is to protect those rights. And so now some
of these things you see being not allowed in one zone, perhaps if they are
already existing, then that's something I'm saying publicly as a communication sort of right
now, we would be interested in trying to help them preserve as
a right. You have down
below where I was just talking about the intermodal containers, jumping back to what we
were discussing, sorry. We have the low-intensity home
occupation use being referenced. Has right
now a 12 nonresident round-trip vehicle trip per day standard.
That's a discussion for another time with our home occupation code. In my
mind would be the standards themselves. We've had some interest in modifying them
a little bit for ag-type small businesses, if you will. But stuff
like this, which is common for home occupations, is also
something that's not easy to enforce. As you can imagine, we can
do a stakeout. In this case, the ARL zone, for whatever
reason, has that number deleted, but still gives the
objective of having small-scale, low-intensity operations.
Comparative similarities in animals and fencing
to a certain extent and the desire to preserve the dark sky
ordinance and keep natural
habitat standards as listed in both codes the same on the books.
Or proposed.
Now, maybe the folks that are here would like to try and characterize farther some
of the differences that they see between the two codes if they've had enough time
to look at them. But the most significant policy changes are
noted at the very bottom of this page in our view. Just to
reiterate, the ARL draft that came late
in the game. Converts the historic ordinance into
a generally applicable rural large lot zone, as we've already talked about.
Number two, it substantially lowers the minimum lot size framework. Three,
it quote removes commercial equestrian operations as a special use and
removes the objective twelve-hour trip threshold for limited equestrian use
or twelve trip. And that's I got that wrong. That's for the lot. And it
deletes the detailed shipping container similar. I'm sorry, could you repeat that? I didn't—
Yeah, I'm just sorry I'm talking quietly because I'm tired, but it's just at the
very bottom of the page with one little correction that should have been in there.
Unfortunately, I can't read
that. Oh, on your screen it's not presenting? Okay. It's very small.
Very small. Oh, well.
Okay, let me try again. Sorry, I'll ramp up my energy a
little bit. I don't know if I can actually blow it up on this overhead
monitor thing, but so once again,
significant changes or differences. You're going
from historic characterization to a zone
that favors other parts of the city if need be. Can be used
there. Drops the minimum lot size down from 5 to 3 acres.
Gets rid of commercial equestrian operations as a special use in
the ARLL. Changes the home occupant standard a
little bit, as we talked about a second— I mentioned a second ago. And deletes
the opportunity for detailed— for shipping containers and semi-trailer
storage regulations. Gets rid of the details on that. So those
are some of the big ones besides the purpose statement.
You know, in any event, I think that'll serve
Brandon, got a way to do it? I guess questions for
staff or the group? Yeah, I've got a couple
questions, things to think about. First of all, I mean, I'm interested what you guys
like the most between those 2 plans or some kind of hybrid
version of it. And then the other thing I was kind of thinking too is,
am I kind of smart for the city since we're putting all this work into
it to create an underlying zone that can be applied anywhere and then maybe put
a historical overlay onto Cedar Pass Ranch that can be used just there
so that we have something that we can use everywhere that we want to put
larger lots? Because I know there's some— we have some planning or some
people on the council that would love to see some larger lots mixed in with
what the other stuff we have. And then then you have that opportunity to put
that in place and still, still preserve a lot of that Cedar
Pass Ranch. And then the other question I had too was, uh,
I know there's been some thought, and I think Craig Whiting has said he's kind
of in favor but doesn't like the idea but would support it, of putting like
some large roads in there to get traffic through the city.
And I don't think I like that idea, but where else do But I
guess it was his thought on some locations that were being considered the best.
So I don't know how that plays into the— So your first
question was, what do we like the most? Yeah, like between these 2 plans,
is there one that you kind of prefer or
some kind of a hybrid of the 2 where we could do like an overlay?
Well, we're here to represent the historical zone.
Right. I'm sorry, I'm the history.
Um, when we learned that a lot of what— a lot
of the language and the work that we did would be very
applicable to a zone for the city,
right, to use in future developments for maybe not
5-acre lots, but something a little bit more like a 2.5 or
a 3-acre development. Sure. We were like, okay, great, yeah, do that.
But some of the things that make us unique probably
can't fit into a smaller lot. Right. Such as like,
I mean, what's not really listed is the size of outbuildings that
we do end up having. You wouldn't be able to fit those onto
your smaller lots. Animal count would be different.
Right, for sure. The shipping container thing, You wouldn't
want those on the smaller lots. So go ahead, Susan.
The animal count thing,
there are not animal limits in Cedar Pass. If you'll step up, yeah.
Sorry. There's not animal limits in Cedar
Pass Ranch, never have been. And the
residents that we've talked to with exception of a few,
don't want these limits. They've already— doing their operations without
the limits. If we were subject to the ARLL,
that is subject to the residential tables in
the code. Sure. Okay. The table referring to the animals. Yeah.
And I think for the purpose of discussion today, let us— let's make sure there's
2 things being discussed, right? The historical district,
which was in cooperation between staff and
the HOA. Correct. Yes. As closely reflecting what was
the intended approval of said development
under the county. That's what I'm getting. And then, then as a natural
reaction, out of that came the large
lot potential zone,
which reflects some aspects of the historic,
but not in— It doesn't accurately reflect
what the residents are doing in Cedar Pass Ranch right now.
Gotcha. So my question for the city is,
aren't large lots already approved under agriculture zone
and the residential large lots?
Aren't 5-acre lots already approved authorized under
agriculture zones? Yes.
As well as under residential zones,
the large land use agriculture residential density
1, which includes— of
course, this is a general question for either.
Let me take a step back. In the recent
past years, the city has taken an approach to amend
existing developments to meet current zones,
right? Rather than creating new zones for
those unique situations. So in
this case, the city is taking an approach to take— create a
new zone for this HOA rather than having it
meet One of the applicable zones, is that correct?
Yes. Okay. And the ag zone and the RA-1
both have a 5-acre minimum. They do. Yes.
So would if all the
history aside, of course, we're not making light of the fact that it was developed
or approved under county, got annexed to the city. But if
if we were applying the same approach. As we've had on other
recent attempts by the city to match
zoning, would the
parcels of the properties under the Cedar
Pass meet the Ag Zone? Would that
be the closest applicable current zone if we were applying
it in the same manner rather than creating a new zone? And Chair,
if you look at the totality of the standards without doing
a detailed analysis, probably so. Because again, the acre standard,
as I already mentioned, as you said, between AG and the RA-1
jive with both historic zone that we're talking about tonight and the
proposed ARL zone too. It's in the nuances of
other details that are in the code that they have proposed that gives some
distinction. Sure. they've wanted as
a community. And to try and sell a generic
zone that we have already to all the community members out there might
or might not go over well. Sure. If this
was a brand new area and it was just being developed now, then I
could see the direction you're talking about. In this case,
although it's not staff's decision, But there's at
least, I think, room to propose something unique.
Commissioner Schum. Yeah,
I have a little bit of knowledge about this whole thing, so I've heard
it for several years, and I think we're making a lot of good moves there.
I do believe there is some validity in
what you said. The agricultural zones that we have in AR-1
covers a lot of the things that we want to do. I understand
where we're trying to do something unique, but there
are 2 things that I don't like in the proposal, and I'll be just
upfront with you.
I hate special use permits. I don't think all that
is is kicking the can down the road for somebody else to have to handle
later. And I, especially in an agricultural
area where people are putting a lot of money into facilities
and things like that— Can I interrupt real quickly?
There's no such thing as a special use permit. That is
a kind of a mixture of a conditional use permit— Okay, I'm sorry.
Which relates to conditional use And a special use is just a permitted use
that has additional special standards elsewhere in the code. So it's
kind of like when you have a conditional use process, you can
put, you know, conditions on granting a conditional use permit.
A special use essentially says, here's our code, these are the conditions in advance.
Okay. Without going through the process. So— But that can change.
So that— I mean, next year, different council,
different— Yes. Planning Commission, they could
come in and say, nope, we don't want to do that. They could also do
that with— even if they're permitted uses, they could remove it as a permitted use.
So yes, a council could change the code in the future. They could adjust the
standards in the future. That's the case no matter what.
Yeah, but especially— If you're engaging in a nonconforming use, that's something different. But I
just want to clarify that there's no such thing as a special use permit.
I said special use and I meant conditional use. Yeah, so there's—
they're not conditional uses. You know, you look at it, they're all special uses,
which means there would be standards set out in the code that
are understood in advance, just like any other standards you would see within
the zoning that would apply for those particular special uses.
Well, and, and the thing I don't like about special
use, conditional use, it's just like may or could
or possible when we're doing Ordinances.
They're too gray. No, I don't agree.
I think they're the same. There's no difference between a P and an
S, except that with the S, there are additional
rules that apply that are in the code. There's no difference between a
P and an S. So if you're okay with a P, then an S is
the same thing, except the standard— there's additional standards that apply to that particular
S.
Okay. I'm still concerned, and I will stay
that way. I just want to clarify the law. I'm not advocating
for or against any particular use. Sure. I want to clarify the law
that permitted use and a special use are the same thing. Special use is just
a term that we use to say that there are additional standards
that apply in the code, and so you need to look to the special use
chapter to see what those. Okay. Whereas a permitted use is
just something that, all right, you're in this zone, it's permitted use.
There's sometimes room for interpretation because, you know,
based on the language used for permitted use, is something that is similar
but maybe not quite the same, or maybe it is the same, does it apply?
There's always going to be things like that that occur in the law. I wish
I could tell you 100% of the time the law is 100% clear. I would
be lying if I said that. We know better than that. But okay,
the other thing I don't like about this is you're treating a 2.5-acre
lot just like a 10-acre lot. In our animal use,
we've learned over the last 5 years that we started
out going up to 3 acres,
and then everything beyond 3 acres was treated the same.
And we found that doesn't work, and we've made amendments to go
to so many animals, and I'm referring to the animal use,
so many animals per acre
when you get beyond there. And so now you're telling the
guy that has 10 acres that he has to abide
to the same building site— What? The same building size,
the same cover
and structure. Let me finish. cover, structure,
protection for their animals.
But he can have more animals, but he can't have— he has
to have this size building. And so I think
I would feel better about it if it was
just like the animal ordinances where the bigger
the lot you get, the more animals you have, the bigger the building.
And it doesn't have to be actually a bigger building, but it has to
be more buildings, different size, different loafing sheds, different structures,
so that you can take care of your animals correctly.
Rather than trying to stuff them in a 2-acre box. 'Cause a 10,000-square-foot
building on a 2.5-acre lot is big.
Here's the thing. A 20,000-square-foot
building on a 10-acre lot It's
not a big deal. So those are the restrictions,
the things that I don't agree with. Can I—
And so, but now I'll let you answer my question. I'm sorry,
I just was wanting a clarification, 'cause I was— you're talking
about 2.5 acres in the ARLL
part? Yeah,
that's— we're advocating for
the historical zone. Which is the 5 acres or more that's
not subject to those tables. But you're still trying to restrict the building to
10— Can you turn your mic on? Oops, I'm sorry. You are still restricting
the building to 10,000 square foot size and 15,000
total. Correct. And there are,
in Cedar Pass Ranch, lots that are substantially bigger
than 5 acres. Correct, and currently there are 2 lots
with existing buildings that are bigger than 15,000 square feet.
And so,
I mean, there are, but— But they're probably on
5 acres. They're on more than 5 acres. And those buildings would be substantially,
they'd look terrible on a 2.5-acre lot. Correct.
And that, but that standard is what we're,
they're different in both. In the zones that we're proposing.
Okay, but you can see where I'm saying that there
are 10-acre lots in Cedar Pass Ranch, or some that are close to that.
There are some somewhere in between. And so all I'm suggesting
is that we look at it and say, okay, you got a 2.5-acre
lot, yeah, 10,000 square foot's a lot.
You got a 10-acre lot, well, maybe 15,000's okay.
Okay, our— And so that would be
my only suggestion, and then actually set up a scale just like
we do with the animals. So a sliding scale is what you're talking about?
Yep. Yeah. That's a good suggestion. Thank you.
Commissioner Allen. Yeah, just kind of going high level on this.
I do agree with the background on it, like that Cedar
Pass Ranch has a special history, and I think because
of Cedar Pass Ranch, we have the Eagle Mountain we do today. It set the
culture, it set the tone, it set the direction of the city. So I do
think it's unique and should be preserved. So I do like the approach of a
special historical district just for Cedar Pass Ranch. It's over 30
years old. Let's maintain that. The character's been established,
so let's put that in stone, and then that will help maintain it in the
future along with the HOA and other things. So I do like the approach
here of that historical zone. I think you've got a lot of good stuff on
here. here, I'm definitely very much in favor of. And then switching over to the
ARLL, if the city does want to pursue this, I agree
with Commissioner Hess that it seems like it's very close to the RA-1 zone.
So if we're going to create a new zone, I think we should be very
careful in building that out and be very— do
it very purposefully, right? So like the 2.5-acre thing,
the minimum, I don't like that. I think bump that to a 5.
Basically a special RA-1 zone. We could choose where
in the city we want this to be, like a little brother to Cedar Pass
Ranch somewhere, right, where we're going to be very careful in saying, hey, we want
this to be another equestrian center. Here's the special uses. So if
this does come back, Rob, and we're doing the ARLL for other portions of the
city— again, I like the historical zone for Cedar Pass Ranch, but if the city
wants to apply the ARLL in other portions of the city,
I would like to have a comparison between it and the existing rural
agricultural zones. Because again, if we're going to make a new zone, let's make
sure it's different enough and has a purpose, which again, I think we could do
another equestrian-type zone. We're going to be careful about where we put
it and do it very purposefully. So thanks.
Did you have a— Commissioner DiCorsi? Yeah, I largely
agree with Commissioner Hess. I think Or sorry, Commissioner Hess and Commissioner
Allen. Chair Hess, sorry, I'll get this right
someday. In terms of the applicability of
an ARLL, but being very thoughtful about how it fits into the
existing framework. On the historical
zone itself, I guess I wonder if a
little more thought needs to be put into where this feels like HOA
type enforcement as opposed to city code.
I don't know, maybe it's— And we can speak to that. We can speak to
that. Go ahead. I mean, does this mirror pretty much the CC&Rs
or the HOA? Does it mirror some of them? No. And we can get you
a copy of our covenants that we
have because we are able to be more restrictive than
the city, and we are.
And it's to try to help just preserve what we have.
Got it. And then we do— and then we try to do what
we can on our monitoring and enforcement of those CC&Rs. Yeah.
So we're not asking the city to come in and police
our CC&Rs. Yeah. Okay. I mean,
there were mostly— I think it was okay. A few of them, maybe the vehicle
trips per day, like that seemed seems like a hard one for the city to
monitor. I think I've seen— I mean, there's at least one lot that's
on the— on SR 73 that looks like it's a commercial,
like, parking lot. I don't know, for lack of a better word, like vehicles
like crazy. And go ahead. And that's part of
the reason why we have been trying to cooperate with the city is because
we do have an enforcement issue in Cedar Pass Ranch with the city that we
have been told by code enforcement officers in the city, that they will not enforce
anything in our area because we have no
zoning. Yeah, so it's an HOA or CDR issue. The enforcement part being if
something starts to become commercial. And— The city
needs to— I mean, that's kind of how it started. That's part of
the history. Whether it's true or not is not for us to debate
today, right? But that's kind of where we were coming from as a committee
working with the city to— in a collaborative effort.
Yeah, sure. That makes sense. I think just in wrapping up, I would say
I hope that we can come to something that doesn't feel like
the city is creating an HOA. Chair?
Yeah. Can I? A couple of points.
So to that question a bit,
initially it was voiced that the idea with this was to create a skeletal
code and to allow the HOA to, to suggest what
they wanted to, but to not go down the path you're talking about. But I
will note what they just said and maybe reiterate it. The city's
understanding of enforcing anything out there in the way of city
code, any city code right now, for the most part, at least zoning
stuff, is that we can't because there's not a zone assigned
to the property. There are some generic things we can deal with, of course,
that are outboard of maybe Title 17. But certain things,
you know, the understanding is no until we get something passed for them, whatever it
is, whether it's something custom or it's generic to the code already.
Commissioner Schronce. Going to
Commissioner Hess's comment, though, if we use—
either way we go, we get a zoning, whether it's the
historical Or it's an AR-1
that we've got on the books right now, that would fix that problem.
Yes, whether we— like you said, to repeat, whether it's historic as
proposed, whether it's the ARL as a last-minute sideline
opportunity, or if it's just a standard code that we have now, zoning,
I mean, RA-1 or Ag or whatever, one of those 3,
then yeah. Yeah. It gives something there for— And
then a comment, or just a question for you two.
I know since I've been in the middle of this for several years,
I know we have HOA CC&Rs
right now, and we have
proposed new CC&Rs, correct?
Correct. And the new CC&Rs would help fix
a lot of the HOA problems enforcement,
correct? That and get us current with state law.
And get current with state law, yeah. So at
that point, it would help— the new CC&Rs would help do what you want to
do with some limitations.
It would help. It would help. The old CC&Rs,
quite frankly, probably are
hard to enforce because a lot of it's illegal.
Right now. It's outdated. Maybe that's a better word.
Is that correct? Yeah, it is. So I was, I was HOA
president in 2022 when I did the rewrite because those CC&Rs
came from Colorado. Yeah. And so we made them applicable in
2002. Did I say '22? 2002.
Now it's been 24 or 25 years and we got
to get current with state code. And so we're in that process. We hope to
accomplish that here in the next short, short few months
because a lot of the work has already been done because it got started 2,
3 years ago of doing a rewrite. So yes, for us to
be able to do enforcement on our end, absolutely, it's going to be helpful.
We have made progress with that corner lot. I don't know if you've noticed,
but there's been improvement in the past 3 Yeah.
Because I told him, you cannot have commercial here.
The city needs to come here also and say, you cannot have commercial here.
I also think there's a— want to reiterate that our CC&Rs
can be restrict— be more restrictive than our code. And I
think there's enough differences in what we're asking for to keep it separate from our
HOA Because we don't want this— we're
not asking you to monitor or police our HOA,
no. But we do want a code that reflects
what the residents have been doing there, that the city can,
one, for help for enforcement, and two,
it helps the residents, you know, solidify in their mind that they're—
we're not going to have another civil war in our neighborhood.
Because we really We really don't want that.
Yeah. Just one more, and, and I understand the
concerns very well, really, really well. Yeah.
Uh, and, and I think what you're trying to do is separate
the agricultural use, which is our history. Correct.
Versus the commercial use, which is people coming in with
their excavators and and all their equipment and putting a big building
up and getting a commercial lot for
half the price of a commercial lot. I think
it's more than just that though. I mean, that is one component. I think we
want to— the feedback that we received was the residents want to stay agricultural
and they do not want to be considered
residential with an agricultural component. They want
to be Agricultural. That's what the feedback has been,
and that's what we're trying to stay. And you're absolutely right.
Everything I've heard has been the same thing. They don't want to be residential.
Correct. So, right. Okay, thanks.
No, I, I guess just without knowing obviously all the
history, but just going off a recent
zoning and what we've been doing,
I can see a benefit of having a historic zone that matches
the uses that have occurred in that
particular site that you want to maintain. You know, Robert presented,
you know, the process by which those
things are grandfathered in. They're not going to change, even whether the zone changes.
Those were— some of those were allowed. My fundamental question
is, Robert, in your process of working
on this, how does the requirement
shown in the historical zone compare to just
the agriculture zone? The 5-acre minimum lots,
it precludes commercial.
I haven't done a full depth here, but instead
of creating a separate zone, How would this line up with just the
agriculture zone, knowing that all of those lots that
have been created historically, those are going to be
conforming, right? But moving forward for
new developments or new things, you would have that limitation.
That would be my fundamental technical question for the city.
All right, well, let me start with a preface to that and understand
that The RA-5 zone paperwork
that we had in office printed off the internet from the county's website,
which even though it has RA as its acronym
or abbreviation in the title, is really, as it says in
the county zone and as was expressed a second ago,
flavored towards agricultural first with a side component or accessory kind
of component of residential. So that was handed to the applicants
as the presumptive zone that they were still maybe under, or at least were
in the county. In the county, but not— Plus the Ag Zone was given to
them. The 1720. Plus the RA-1 was given to them, if I recall correctly.
Oh, okay. So that was the basis of some of the discussions, like, here's this.
Here's a starting point. Here's a starting point, and let's do a skeletonized version.
That draft zone code was very simple, was given to them as well to start
fleshing out. And I didn't have the
time to do an absolute comparison, but I'll show you one thing. Look at this.
Now I've got the ARL table up. I guess I could move to the— let's
see, see if I can get— And your ARLL
is proposed, but it's not shown
anywhere currently on the code. It's the— all along it was the historic
zone that was proposed. And by the way, don't forget we have that Historic chapter
that was added in the code to deal with unique situations to include historic
question marks.
So that was the march that we you know that
was the the effort that was underway was to create
something like that, right? And then
towards the end of that process, not that long ago,
it was suggested to staff that. There ought to be consideration for this other zone
as well, to maybe be used or usable for other areas
in the city. So that
information was transmitted back to the HOA group and committee, and they kindly took
what they had with guiding principles and crafted and created this
ARL zone. And so you have
the two, in a sense, competing, obvious preference given to one.
By most, but there's still reason to consider
the other, right? And we're just laying on the table for you.
Or as was already mentioned tonight, maybe there's one of
the existing city zones that's used for this instead. Maybe not
preferable in the minds of many, but in any event, some kind of
zoning has to be given over that property, whatever it is that's
appropriate. Now, one key difference I can show you readily
to answer your question about some of that in the way of
what's distinct. Look at this land use chart that is
part and parcel to the newly proposed— I pulled up the historic
zone instead of the other one. Notice the entries in it.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 different line entries.
And now look at the egg zone.
A lot more callouts, and a lot of them not even
relevant. Look at hog or poultry farm. Great,
it's not allowed as the use. Okay, not allowed in the other proposed zone,
but not even needful. They're not going to have that. In all likelihood,
in their community, right? At this juncture,
so there's one. The animals are described to be similar.
The animals out there, the quantity and the types are treated
as the same as with an ag zone. So in that case, that beckons
back to your point: that's similar. And if
you want, I could always run a comparable if
we wanted to belay what goes to council as a. you know,
working set of documents and come back to you guys for further comment. It just
delays things a bit. But we could also make that part and parcel of
what happens as we bring this back for formal review at
a public hearing setting. In any event,
as you please.
Okay. Commissioner Strong? Just one comment.
I know how much work you put into this, and I— a
lot of people put into this, and I really appreciate that,
'cause I know it's been a tough one, and unfortunately,
there's a lack of documentation, and things happening
over the last 20-plus years.
And so, you ought to get a badge
for taking this one on, I guess is the best way to put it.
Well, a lot of people should.
Okay, any other questions for staff or our
group presentation for individuals? Just a question.
I think I might know the answer, but is there anything that
can be done to, I mean, maybe give this new ordinance some teeth that help
protect it against somebody coming in and just finding a few
buyers, sellers who are willing to sell, maybe they're retiring, whatever, and then they grab
that land and They convince a few council members to vote and change the zoning,
and then they start developing their large apartments in 20 years,
you know, or whatever they want to do because they're right there by the freeway,
by the new freeway, you know, and all that kind of thing.
Sure. So just when— and buying and doing what?
Well, yes, all the time in cities people go buy land and then
work on getting it rezoned and to develop, you know, and that kind of thing.
And in a growing city, that's It's very common to see that people
try to go that route. I mean, they may or may not be successful,
but they'll definitely try. And I don't know if there's anything we can put into
the new zone to kind of help protect against
that happening. Certainly. I appreciate your concerns about that
because that has been on our mind from almost from day one.
Our CC&Rs prohibit subdividing.
You cannot be Any smaller.
We made one exception to a 10-acre lot a number
of years ago so that they so it could be more usable,
but that was the only exception. But you cannot subdivide.
Back to trying to help protect.
Back in 2005.
Alpine School District wanted to come into Cedar Pass Ranch and tear down 2 houses
to build an elementary school.
And we were fortunate enough to be able to send Brett Wright and
my wife and present to Alpine School District what
is Cedar Pass Ranch and educate them.
And one of the big things was there was so much open space. Is there
not room for a school somewhere where there's open space? Why do you have to
come into Cedar Pass and tear down two houses?
And by the way, we don't have any sidewalks. We don't
have any protection for our children who live outside of the busing distance.
We also have 276 horses.
We have, I mean, and so the protections.
Yes, we've had a lot of challenges
of people thinking, oh, this would be a good fit for Cedar Patch Ranch,
but it hasn't been. We've had a
group home try to come in. And so I
appreciate your comments on that. Yeah, and I think— There's future concerns too
about how do— how does the city maybe help maintain
the roads that we have? because they're country roads. Sure.
And we don't have a really good way to put future sidewalks
in. And then the sides of our roads, the side
grass or whatever it is, is where we often have our people
do when they're walking or riding their horses. Yeah,
and maybe that's where we could consider something of like tying
it in with an existing zone to put in the things that you guys have
created. I think those are— yeah, those are starting to get a little complicated.
Yeah, well, I think I might paraphrase, uh,
our counselor, and if he gets— if I get this wrong, he'll of course
correct me. But we've heard legal counsel say
something to the effect that we can't bind this council
we have now, and yourselves of course can't bind a future council. So through
the regular process of say, a code amendment and possibly rezoning
had to go with it, maybe something could change.
But as you just heard, as you remember, HOA covenants
are contracts. You buy into that contract when you buy property. So they can be
amended too. But it's probably
more difficult most of the time to do that.
Commissioner Jensen.
I would imagine, and it's a question, if we're
designating it more as a historical zone, it would provide
the protections against people coming in to develop,
doesn't it? Wouldn't it?
Not necessarily. It's not that kind.
Over what specifically? Over someone coming in to develop. To develop
and, like, grandma and grandpa pass away,
they give it to the kids, the kids sell it for development. If it is
a historical zone— I think at this point it would have to
be Eagle Mountain City coming in and doing eminent domain in order
to see a need to do something different
with that land.
A developer right now— Cannot come in. Cannot. But if it's
designated historical, they can't ever. Well,
yeah, I think a couple things. They have HOA covenants
that obviously control— have
control over the majority of the issue. The lacking support from the
city is the zoning. And we can't preclude any piece
of property from the possibility of a potential rezoning of
any type. In any future time frame, right? Yes.
Not that that would— that's not necessarily the intent.
Hopefully it's helping to, to, you know,
make it clear. But in the future, who knows what
anybody would do on a piece of property that's interested in buying it.
HOA covenants, a new zone, or, or a rezoning zone would,
would provide direction to that as well, but it doesn't preclude Anybody?
Chair, that's correct. It's, it's the labeling of historic is
a little bit different in this manner than what you may be thinking of,
Commissioner, with, for example, historic downtown areas or special
residential areas where they have some very strict standards. You can't even change
your shingles in some places without getting approval. But even in those cases,
the code can be changed to change that up. It might not be easy.
It depends on a lot of decision makers' personalities and what they have
on the books that they want to try and follow in the spirit of law,
all that stuff. I mean, there's all kinds of things about that. But in this
case, it's not that. Yeah. You know, and as we come
together with the zoning, and is
there an instance where we really need the city's help? It would be where the
city has more teeth than what we do.
And we had that 15
years ago. We had somebody take their lot and start mining on it and
selling off what they were scraping
off of their hillside. But the city couldn't— Edwood didn't have
the ability to do anything. And so in our little means,
we gave them a fine and we fine them every month.
But they were making money on top
of us. And so this would allow the
city to be able to come in, and if there was something really egregious,
you would have more teeth to it than us with a small little
fine. Commissioner Strong?
Yeah, just was just thinking, you know, we've got—
we're looking at an agricultural historical site or
code. And we're looking at an agricultural AR-1
code. Is there anything we could take from the historical
code to take a look at our standard agricultural and say,
maybe some of that would not
be bad in, or marry the two, use some of
the, 'cause there's, we've got lots up along the hillside there,
we've got 'em down I know there are some over on the west side that
are agricultural,
equestrian-type places, and maybe it would help
enhance the agricultural code a little. Well, Chair and Commissioner,
if we're talking about the historic zones chapter in Title 17, it sounds
like that's what you're referencing. Having largely
authored that, I can tell you that that was intended to be
a band-aid all along. It's there to factor in
the problem that we have old zones that
were referenced in master development agreements and on our books in some cases
that are no longer there, no longer in our books. And so
it allowed for us to create equivalencies such that if someone had
a question about— a zoning question about their property, instead of
trying to make up an answer and say, well, your property is like unto this
zone that we still have on our books, it's current, and so we're going to
apply that to you. Now what that new language allowed us to do was
to say, actually, we are allowed to make that decision formally
and treat you that way without having to just pull it out of a hat.
And some zones were shown in there as being like unto,
you know, this zone or that zone. And there are others that we get to
make a distinction on. If we can't— if it's not clear, staff gets to make
that call, appealable, of course. So in the
text of it, other than maybe,
like we've already talked about, drawing off another zone like the RA-1 or the Ag
or something and saying that's close to this, there's nothing else to that
that would make that kind of enhancement that you're talking about. Okay.
I think your comment about maybe putting
those side by side so we can compare those 2 would
help me understand a little better. So that's probably a good idea.
Okay, good discussion. I guess it's always,
you know, the eye of the beholder, the profitability
of the discussion. But I don't know if the
purpose, if we're trying to reach a particular particular outcome with our discussion today?
Are you seeking some particular recommendations from us or
just— It's just a discussion at this point. Just a discussion, yeah. Yeah, no,
no, I'm not talking about anything official, but like if we, you know, if we
said, hey, why don't we compare these 2, the other 2 closely related questions.
I think what we've done is synthesize through all this some salient talking points
or things that you've offered up, concerns, pros, cons, that kind Okay.
That then those involved in
drafting this code and bringing it forward to the city, this cooperative
effort, can react to in one of two ways. Either embed
that material or change things a little bit and then bring it back
here, for example, if the time delay is okay with all
the parties involved, or advance it forward and just say to
council, like, here's the situation, kind of like done tonight.
And then, by the way, here are some thoughts that the commission had. They're going
to see that anyway, probably, if they look at the meeting
minutes, you know, the audiovisual. Okay,
'cause eventually the— similar
to what we did, what the city did for the most recent rezone,
I can't remember the name of it. Scenic, is it Scenic Mountain?
That was the most recent one where we, You know, it was simple
because we had a really known, very close-related zones.
And we— but you have to— you have to public notice it,
right? And you have to say, hey, we're officially, you know,
changing these zones on each of these parcels to match
this. So that's the point that eventually we'll
get to here. Correct. The goal. And so
the goal is to Option one,
get the Cedar Pass Ranch historical
zone through the proper channels
to be part of the codified.
Then you would proceed with that approach. The other
option is you you would have to either amend it, continue to amending it back
and forth to get to some agreeable spot between the city and the
HOA or or residents of the the neighborhood
or take the other approach of trying to put them into a related
zone so that you could get underlying zone.
Okay. Chair, that's correct. Yeah, okay. First comes the code, however it
gets there, or else a city existing code. And then yes,
rezoning like if we do Cedar Mountain. Okay. After the fact.
Okay. All right,
Brandon has a question. Uh, yeah, I just— Rob's done a great
job working on this with, with the app— with the, uh, citizens.
One thing I don't want to do, one thing I don't want to see
happen is I think we really need to
focus on this his agriculture, the,
the Cedar Pass Ranch Historical Zone, and not get caught Off,
you know, go off on tangents on on this
or that thing. I think we can come back to them after the fact,
after we get the zone passed. But I I'm
even concerned about even trying to do the ARLL zone at the
same time. I just think that there's been
so much work and it's taken a long time to get momentum going.
I don't want to see that stopped. Let's just get the zone done and we.
Come back to, to, uh, the other things that
we've, we've discussed.
So I would probably— I won't
speak for all the commissioners here, this is just my personal,
um, thought— is, is the ARLL I think could clearly
wait. You know, it's a little confusing reviewing it.
I don't know if everybody, all the commissioners understood that very well,
but to address the
very particular need of the proposed historic district
or zone. So any other final thoughts from
the Commission? OK, again, thank you everyone for your time,
for the work that you're putting into this. We appreciate that.
And that will end our agenda item for the discussion.
With that, there Our next meeting is—
someone's going to find the calendar before me—
the 22nd. Anybody aware,
Commission, if you will be out of town on the 22nd?
I probably won't be here. Okay. I'll be out of town.
You'll be out of town? Okay. All right. Okay. So just if anything
changes for the rest of us, let me know ahead of time.
Okay. With that, our final agenda
item is adjourn. I'll entertain a motion to adjourn.
Oh, sorry, Brandon, just one quick question. Um, just bringing
this back to your attention, went out to Meta
today on a tour. Any interest? I know I had a couple of the
commission members respond back to me. Just wanting to,
I guess, do a quick check with you to see if you're— if the
council's interest or the Commission's interest in going out to Meta
for a tour. It's up to you. We can do it.
We talked about maybe October or November.
It would be an hour and a half type thing. I would be interested in
it. Is there anybody that's not interested in
doing something like that?
I would probably be interested, depending on the time. Yeah, I would be interested.
I don't want you to change the schedule to meet my schedule, but— Sure.
You know.
One thought we could do is— anyway,
well, we'll figure out the logistics. I think we could— it's
gonna have to be some type of public meeting. Yeah, you— yeah.
So we'll work that out, but I'll let them
know that there is interest in doing it.
I understand that work is an issue, so.
Great, thank you, Brandon. Okay, I make
a motion that we adjourn our meeting at 8:03.
Second. Okay, all in favor? Aye. Thank you.